okay icloud is building a private
browser into ios 15. i just upgraded my
ipad and my iphone to ios 15. it's got
some cool features uh one of the
features i like is when you share an
apple music link when you go to apple
music and you play the track it shows
you who shared it with you just just
kind of like a nice little elegant touch
of imessage moving over uh into apps
right where you can see who forwarded
you that another interesting piece uh
that's notable is i believe facetime is
now able when you do a facetime group
call you're able to get people into that
call who are on android so lots of
interesting you know features and i
think actually that
when you share a podcast as well it will
say jason shared this pocket with you so
sms all your friends your this week in
startups and all in and you get credit
for it in their app when they're playing
it just gives a little notice that this
was shared with you by jcal okay so back
episode 1204 on this week in startups we
talked about how apple was introducing
uh app tracking transparency this forces
developers to ask users if they want
their data shared so apple has been on
this mission to protect your privacy not
in china not in russia but here in the
usa you know they obviously have to
abide by local laws and so
um its privacy is their selling point
they are pitting themselves as the
anti-facebook and the anti-google that
is apple selling point and you know what
people are buying it we always said at
some point people are going to care
about privacy well i think it's actually
happening because apple which is just
absolutely world class at taking
complicated features and making them
simple
is doing that you may have seen one
feature where when you sign up
for an app
it says hey would you like to sign up
with your email or would you like to
mask your email just a nice little
elegant touch there where you can keep
some of your privacy and apple enforce
that on people if you want to have your
app in the app store you have to offer
apple login and so apple login is
becoming a thing when facebook does
facebook login they're doing it to track
you around the web
that's why they're doing facebook
connect login they want to track you get
data on you and then sell it when apple
does it right
apple login is not so apple can get data
on you because they don't monetize your
data
what they do with your data is nothing
they store it on your phone and they
will not let anybody have it as we know
from the san bernardino uh terrorist
shooting case where they wouldn't unlock
the phone i mean they if they won't
unlock a terrorist phone they're not
going to unlock yours so i think that's
a pretty reasonable position we can all
agree on so
apple is now uh created
a private relay and it's in beta uh and
the ipad is part of this so what it does
basically is you will not be tracked
when you're using safari and so it's a
really slick feature you can turn it on
as you see here in the video
and when you go search around the web
it's basically like i guess you could
think of it like tour i'm not sure
exactly how they're doing the private
relay but the idea is whatever you're
searching for it's even better than say
being in incognito mode because even in
incognito mode or private mode they
still have your ip address and they
might have ways of identifying you with
this
what they're doing is uh like a vpn or
you know maybe like the tour network
when you send your request in safari
they go and collect the page for you and
then serve it to you and they're like
this intermediary i believe if somebody
thinks it's different let me know and as
somebody said in the live audience here
part of the notey gang uh jeko says just
use the brave browser brave browser is
another uh great browser for removing
tracking but
having it on
the phone and having the hardware work
towards protecting your privacy is a
major major step in
all of our privacy being
protected so in the announcement on the
website normally when you browse the web
information containing your web traffic
such as your dns records and your ip
address can be seen by your network
provider and websites you visit so
network providers will also collect this
information
about what you visit and they might be
selling it or they might have agreements
with the googles and facebooks and
advertisers of the world so all your
data is being shared in many different
ways and so uh when that data is shared
you can be identified located you get
the idea so the first relay is operated
by apple it allows your iop address to
be seen by your network provider but
your dns records are encrypted so
neither party can see web addresses you
are accessing and the second relay is
operated by a quote third-party content
provider it creates a temporary ip
address and decrypts the website's
address connecting you to the site
you're trying to reach so just like i
said maybe a little bit like the tor
network if you're aware of that which
has you know multiple hops and
all kinds of bad people use that for bad
reasons you know not not just for
privacy so i think it's another huge win
for apple and i think it's something
they're going to be able to keep putting
pressure um and differentiating
themselves versus android and versus
facebook and this is really going to
impact their businesses and i think
apple because they make their profits
from selling you hardware that is
massively overpriced you can opt to pay
for that what would i do if i was
facebook i would come up with facebook
vip
i would come up with android or google
vip where if you pay google a hundred
dollars a year ten dollars a month you
get an ad free experience and no
tracking both of those companies should
do that now
because that would then give them the
high road when they get pulled in front
of congress senators and legislators and
people who want to break up big tech
just very simple all you have to do is
say
period end of story
uh if you want to have a free service
you pay with advertising and we sell
your data in an anonymous way to
advertisers and you see target
advertising or you can pay 10 bucks a
month you're paying 15 bucks a month for
netflix pay 10 bucks a month for our
services
you know arguably you get more from
youtube and google than you do from
netflix right if you could only have one
google and youtube
or netflix which would you pick i mean
it's a pretty obvious choice you would
go with google
and youtube so i pay for youtube to turn
the ads off i would pay for google to
turn the ads off so uh there have been
some uh app tracking transparency
features uh that are rippling through
the advertising space i'm seeing it in
some startups who are worried about this
where you used to be able to target
people a little bit more
aggressively and actually casper
mattress recently announced they were
laying off their cmo cto and co and an
anonymous founder in the dt space told
techcrunch these layers were likely due
to casper's difficulty selling product
since the change is made retargeting
much less effective you know to find
valuable uh customers iphone users so
let me explain that and unpack what
they're saying there it could be that
casper is just a company that has had
its best day and companies like eight
sleep are a better product
and full disclosure i'm a modest
investor in eight sleep and a fan of the
product i use it every night in fact
but putting that aside
what's happening here is uh you used to
be able to do something called
look alike and retargeted audiences what
that means is you say hey here's the
customers who bought casper mattresses
and then the algorithm at facebook and
google says okay here's more people like
that and they use any number of data
sources and algorithms to figure that
out well apple is saying yeah you can't
do that anymore we're not going to let
you track people on their phones
and what that means is those look-alike
audiences and that retargeting is much
less effective now you're just maybe
targeting an audience by geo location or
just americans or just iphone users
right and iphone users uh you know they
may be a small percentage of all phone
users but they happen to skew as the
most profitable customers in the world
so what apple is really doing is
they're just
really decimating google and facebook's
ability to target
the best most elite users and that is uh
makes this a very entertaining uh thing
to watch
in today's startup landscape committing
to security and compliance is vital for
growth and proof of your company's
security posture has never been more
important as you scale you might start
to receive more sock 2 requests from
customers and that's where drata comes
in trada is an advanced automation
platform used by some of the world's
leading chief information security
officers or csos strata will help you
successfully meet requirements support
enterprise deal flow and continually
track compliance strata also helps
customers easily prepare for and clear
sock 2 and other audits so you can go
from zero to audit ready in a matter of
weeks need more take it from philip
martin chief security officer at
coinbase and here's his quote it became
clear to me right away that drata is an
engineering powerhouse the solution
they've developed is well ahead of other
market players their approach to deep
native integrations provides users with
the most advanced automation available
so check out drata's five-star reviews
on g2 and see why companies like clear
close smart recruiter and the good face
project work withdrawda for their
compliance needs twist listeners can get
fifteen percent off and waived
implementation fees at drata.com twist
d-r-a-t-a dot com slash twist